- Much respect as this
series comes to an end.
- A magnificent Game 7 performance,
sending home the Clippers.
- What a battle.
- The Los Angeles Lakers
eliminate the Houston Rockets.
- Frustration for the Bucks.
- Question from Jonathan
down in the bubble.
- TNT.
- Right over here.
- So much has happened in the NBA bubble.
- Uh-oh.
- Was that an ankle?
- So as a journey comes to an end—
- A shocking upset.
- The best team in the NBA is gone.
- We're asking players to
give us their last word
on their NBA bubble experience.
So what are your last words
on this bubble experience?
- [Laughing] Last word?
Um...
- Um, last words would be...
- That's tough for me right now.
- I don't know what you want me to say,
but I just lost, so I don’t really
care what go on in the bubble now.
- I'm ready to go home.
- Guess I get to see my
kids and my family.
- Not really sure.
Next question.
- The bubble is a bubble.
It was challenging.
It was an experiment.
An experience.
- Ending on the loss,
disappointed, of course.
But, you know, it's an
experience I'll never forget.
- Our mission was to come down here
and be the last team standing.
We fell short of that.
- I think that whoever's crowned champion
deserve it cuz it's definitely the
toughest time I've had in the NBA.
- Obviously it didn't end how we wanted
it to, but, overall the experience.
A lot of ups and downs, a lot
of craziness in this world.
I'm just happy that the NBA,
you know, myself can give
something and for the world to
be excited about and proud about.
♪♪♪ We celebrate the healing scars.
Back to back like it's no tomorrow. ♪♪♪
- I thought it was good.
We didn't end up accomplishing what
we wanted to and what we needed.
But I thought we had a lot of fun.
- Pain that's on my face right now, the
way I feel, I can only imagine what’s
going through these victims’ families.
- I think the job is getting done
as far as what we came here for.
And I'm not talking about
finishing the season.
I'm talking about coming
together as a brotherhood and
getting our message across.
- First time guys have ever worn
these messages on their jerseys
that I can, that I know of,
especially for this amount of time.
And, you know, the main thing that
we were trying to do here was push
that message as well as play a game
that we love, that that’s our job.
- There's a lot of injustice still
happening with the Black community.
- Justice for Breonna Taylor.
Justice for everybody—well, every
Black American out there that are being
harmed by police and police brutality.
- I appreciate the NBA and everybody
listening for continuing to preach
that message because it’s not stopping.
- The job isn't done yet.
And we can't stop until
Black lives really do matter.
- I ain't gonna lie to you.
A few months ago when they told
us about the bubble, none of us
were really excited about it.
- We were all skeptical coming into it.
Just, you know, it was unprecedented
times, not knowing what's gonna go on.
- Obviously playing in a place like this
with no family, no fans, it was tough.
- We’re happy with the way we have
had to keep the game of basketball
going at the highest level and at
the same time, keep people safe.
- The NBA did a good job of,
you know, hosting this event.
- As a whole, I think they made it
really, they made it really fun for us.
It’s a basketball paradise.
- It was also very fun to compete
against so many peers, you know, in
this space, this AAU-like atmosphere.
- It was way more than I expected.
Super fun.
Gave me a chance to bond with
my teammates and get closer and
get back to the game I love.
- I just wanna say thank you to everybody
that prepared the food, that made
everything as comfortable as can be for
the players and everybody staying here.
I really am grateful for your sacrifice.
- I just wanna thank everyone that
was involved in this bubble.
You guys made it, you know,
much easier for us to be here.
- The NBA did an unbelievable job
keeping everything professional
and us protected, and we have to
continue to keep that momentum going.
- Our run is over and, you know, I'll
continue going back to doing my work.
- We will use our platform and
able to not only compete on
the court, but be champions off
the court for our communities.
- We used our platform for our voices
to be heard on the social injustices.
- You know, we're still trying to send
a message and talk to the world, and
we’re still gonna keep doing that.
♪♪♪ Celebrate the progress,
that’s how we mobbin’ ♪♪♪
- To come together as a group and
try to figure out ways to continue
to impact society, I think
we've continued to do that and
hopefully we continue to uplift.
- We made a difference in the
world with our short time here.
And it's gonna continue to be a good
thing for for everybody in the league.
- For me, I turn my focus back, you know,
to some of these problems that we have
going on and being able to help out, you
know, help out in whatever ways I can.
- Definitely one experience of a
lifetime, and it's something that
we never thought would happen.
- It was a tough process, but, you
know, I was glad I was a part of it.
You're all part of history.
- I think overall it shows that basketball
will continue throughout any event.
Basketball will always
bring people together.
We can have a voice while playing
basketball, and I'll be there
in another bubble if it happens.
- So I think that the bubble
was a success and, yeah, time
to leave this motherf--ker.